[Music]
the ruins of Gaza City destruction and
death the sound of an Israeli military
drone
above and more accusations of war crimes
committed by the Israeli
[Music]
Army the stairs lead to an apartment of
a family
home
[Music]
bullet
cartridges broken and abandoned
belongings walls and Floors covered in
blood can never
[Music]
forget tanks and bulldozers surrounded
the building shells had been hitting the
building for days the situation was
desperate on the 19th of December
Israeli soldiers entered the building
they smashed on our apartment door my
husband opened it and told them we were
all
civilians they took him to another
apartment I followed them pleading with
them to let him go because we were all
civilians there were no members of the
resistance
here they beat me and my daughters they
put us women in one place and threat US
with guns and knives they made us strip
they searched us insulting us and using
the most terrible words they took our
names and filmed us may God bestow his
Mercy on the 19 men in this building
they killed my husband was one of them
they ordered them to bend down and
executed them they killed them
all these pictures obtained exclusively
by Al jazer were shot just hours after
the events omo
describes the bodies of men
entry holes of bullets in their
back um's daughter says when the
killings had been carried out shells
started hitting the building
again ashen-faced
exhausted and scared she holds the tiny
shirt worn by her three-year-old sister
NADA who died in her
arms the family shelters in a dark cold
room injured children children stay
close the girl lays wounded on the floor
there is little
food except soup to
[Music]
eat the soldiers came in and separated
the women and the children from the men
they kept us in the sitting room while
they executed the man outside I was
holding my sister in my arms then the
Shon resumed n was hit she made some
soft no noises she asked for some water
I thought she was crying but she was
dying shrapnel had entered her head eyes
and neck my sister tried to carry the
body but she fell from her arms at the
door nada's eyes were still open as she
passed away the wounds to her head too
shocking to
show a young family broken by the horror
of the Israeli Army's killing and
destruction in the Gaza Strip and
knowing it's likely that no one will
ever be tried for what they saw and the
pain they continue to endure Charles
stford Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer